how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays my segment where you all Smit
your theories each week I pick five and
then you vote on which one was your
favorite
this week we have some really good and
interesting theories that were submitted
if you would like to submit your own
theory for a chance to end up an episode
you can find the email to send it to and
the instructions in the description down
below
alright so let's dive into some theories
the first one comes from Chris Godfrey
and Chris has a theory about dr. strange
Chris says that he doesn't think dr.
strange was really dusted but he wanted
Thanos to believe he was dead
so using his magic he mocked the effect
of his dusting he says think of Izanagi
from Naruto that allows the self to use
a certain plan of actions and if killed
or injured badly will undo the wounds
giving a chance to try a new strategy
maybe he manipulated his fate to be
dusted then using a set Izanagi like
ability undid his death Chris believes
that he then hides in either the mirror
dimension dark dimension quantum realm
or other somewhere he won't be detected
by Thanos but he will return before a
crucial time to help but he also could
have taken some of the other Avengers
who were on Titan as well Chris says
think about it isn't it weird that the
50/50 snap took all the guardians of the
galaxy except for rocket along with
spider-man and Doctor Strange leaving
only Iron Man and nebula on Titan it
could have been chance or there is a
plan that has not yet unfolded but
Doctor Strange isn't one to leave things
to chance so either he has a specific
plan that doesn't rely on his presence
to be a hundred percent sure or he will
be there to manipulate events to ensure
the victory this is a good theory and
honestly not something that I would put
past Doctor Strange after all he is the
master of the mystic arts and like Chris
said he doesn't leave things to chance
hence why he went forward in time and
saw all of the difference in areas I'm
not sure if he could have prevented all
of the other heroes from being snapped
away but I definitely think that he
could somehow prevent himself from being
snapped away so I would definitely not
be surprised if we saw Doctor Strange
wind up in Avengers and games still
alive not really being dusted so that's
it for theory number one let's go to
theory number two theory number two
comes from Niko Gonzales and Niko says
that an Avengers endgame Tony will
record the
we see in the first trailer for pepper
then start thinking about all the things
that have happened up to this point him
becoming Iron Man
saving the world multiple times fallen
in love with pepper and then he
remembers the dream that he had about
having a child with pepper after this he
stands up and realizes that nebula has
been watching him he walks past her and
she asks him where he's going and he
says I'm not going to die like this he
starts tinkering with a part of the ship
and nebula taps him on the shoulder he
turns around to see nebula holding
Rockets toolbox and she says I'll help
cut to later Tony and nebula land in
Wakanda and are instantly charged at by
the remaining people of Wakanda having
just lost most of their people that what
Condon's don't know who to trust Tony
and nebula fend off a few but soon they
are surrounded by the wakandans and one
of them yells state your purpose Tony
says we just returned from fighting an
alien with a glorified min the wakandans
realizing Tony is on their side explain
what happened and Tony says I need to
find the Avengers but first I need a new
suit the wakandans give Tony anything he
needs to make his new suit eventually
Tony asked for the strongest metal that
they have and they give Tony a dimension
they call it a sacred metal in which is
stronger than vibranium and even they
don't have a lot of it
Tony studies the vibranium and Adam in
tiem and figures out that there are both
advantages and disadvantages to both so
he ends up using both in the suit and
calls it the bleeding edge armor I like
this theory especially since I've done a
video on how Tony Stark could possibly
make a vibranium Iron Man suit it would
make sense that at some point in time
Tony
ends up in Wakanda they're the most
technologically advanced city in the
world and Tony is going to need a better
suit to fight Thanos since he already
lost with his old suit and it would be
crazy cool if somehow the wakandans had
adamantium which would be a little node
to Wolverine so this is something I
could definitely see happening and I
really would hope they would say
something about adamantium so that's
theory number two onto number three
number three comes from Elijah Morris
and Elijah states that the Russo
brothers followed way closer to the
comics than we thought and Lady Death is
actually in the movie when Fay knows
does the snap and appears in the soul
world after talking to Gamora he is
actually speaking to Lady Death who does
have the power to transform into other
figures and travel within the Infinity
stones and in the comics there was a
special
when death revealed herself to Thanos
and revealed her intentions to him in
the first place
Thanos wiped out half of the plants and
animals too which was counterproductive
to his plan as well as lied about
gomorrah's planet flourishing this was
because his real goal was never to do
that balancing of the universe the
villain of the MCU is not an
eco-terrorist it was to follow death and
do whatever she said for him to do
regardless of his reason he is confused
by her temptations also the only reason
he really loved Gamora is because death
has been appearing to him in that form
for a long time and he confuses his love
for death with Gamora he truly is
cold-hearted and only loves Gamora
because of his love for mistress death
when he is speaking to baby Gamora this
is confirmed by her saying did you do it
how much did it cost
Elijah thinks this is one of the
conversations that he has had all the
time with death because like in the
comics she has been disturbing him
throughout his childhood since he was a
child this is a weird consultant he goes
to and goes too often baby Gamora and
the soul world is Lady Death that's why
she had her own little altar thing where
she was standing in Soul world when he
saw her there she is a deity and the
creepy music plane plays onto his
derangement his troubled face plays to
his real intentions this is certainly an
interesting take on Lady Death she is a
huge part in the comic she is the whole
reason fan OHS does the snap and in the
post-credits scene of the first Avengers
movie they referenced death so she
clearly exists in the MCU
and Elijah is right him killing half of
the plants and the animals is
counterproductive to his plan so perhaps
lady death does appear to Thanos in the
form of baby Gamora and fan oohs has
actually talked to her very often
throughout time and his real reason for
performing the snap is for Lady death so
that's theory number three on to theory
number four theory number four comes
from Susan Dolan and Susan says that
despite all the hoopla over the quantum
realm and time-travel she personally
thinks that it's all misdirection to
create hype ant-man gets out of the
quantum realm the same way he did last
time blue growth disk in his regulator
finding Hank Janet and Hogan he tries to
get a hold of Lewis and his company and
Kent seeing all of the chaos caused by
the snap Scott does the only thing he
can do finds the Avengers with Hank
Pimm's lab and shrunken form rocket
takes half of the
into space while Thor takes the other
half to net a Valier via Stormbreaker
for weaponry rocket rescues Tony and
nebula rocket then takes them to net a
Valier and Tony and rocket do what they
do best
Thor travels to the remaining seven
realms to raise an army against Thanos
he then astro travels to Valhalla to get
Loki and possibly Odin to put Loki on
the throne of Jotunheim to recruit the
frost giants the battle may start on
Titan too but it will end on sanctuary
as Tony's vision in age of Ultron with
Thanos his death and the reversal of the
snap
then Doctor Strange once more in
possession of the time stone erases
everything famous did and no one has any
clue as to what happened
hence no one mentioning it in spider-man
far from home because Peter never left
the bus and he got to go to the Museum
of Modern Art Susan says that there are
two possibilities for the in credit
baddie only two mangog and Archon I
believe that this theory could be true
based on the sole fact that the Russo
brothers are the kings at troll eNOS yes
they are making us think that the
Avengers will go back in time via the
quantum realm but they made us think a
lot for Avengers infinity war and they
did say that we truly have no idea what
Avengers in games going to be about but
we all think it's about time travel so
does that mean it's not about time
travel and also I think the Avengers
going to neduvaali R makes perfect sense
Thor and rocket were just there they saw
how powerful Stormbreaker is so why
wouldn't the Avengers have weapons made
out of metal plus this happens in the
fear itself' comic storyline the
Avengers all go to neduvaali R and they
all get weapons which is something I
think would be really awesome to see an
in-game but something that makes perfect
sense as well and of course it does make
perfect sense that the final battle
would end on the sanctuary just like in
Tony's vision in age of Ultron so that's
it for Theory number 4 on to the final
theory theory number 5 theory number 5
comes from harris bolin from Malaysia
and Harris thinks that all the scenes
that we saw in the second Avengers
in-game trailer with all the destruction
in the background is Xander because
behind nebula in this scene he thinks he
can see some Nova Corps ships which were
probably destroyed by Thanos in the
first act where he went to get the power
stone from Xander because an Avengers
infinity war they didn't show this scene
but Thor does say that Thanos decimated
Xander and Harris thinks that the reason
they didn't show an Avenger
finiti wort is because they will show it
in Avengers in game and Hera says that
you can also see a little purple behind
Captain America which is probably them
fighting Thanos with the power stone
this could be their first strike against
Thanos on Xandar once ant-man has
arrived but they will fail at first
which explains the time jump between
Natasha's hair changing
I think this theory makes perfect sense
I think that we definitely did not see
fan o's get the power stone from Zander
in Avengers infinity work because we're
going to see it in endgame and since the
Power Stone is the first stone that
Thanos collects it would make sense that
they would go to Xandar
to try and stop him from getting the
first one and Harris does make some good
points about what we see from the
trailer there does seem to be a little
bit of purple in the background in
Captain America scene and it does look
like there could be some remains of Nova
Corps ships behind nebula and if this is
the first attack that the Avengers do on
Thanos it will probably take place
within the first 15 to 20 minutes of the
movie and Kevin Feige said that the
footage in the trailer will most likely
only be from the first 15 to 20 minutes
of the movie so this theory could make a
lot of sense so that's it for this
week's theories let's do a quick recap
theory number one is that dr. strange is
not really dusted he used a spell to
make famous believe that he was dusted
but he will come back and play a big
role in Avengers in game theory number
two is that Tony Stark and nebula will
end up in Wakanda and Tony Stark will
build a new Iron Man suit out of
vibranium and Adam in tiem theory number
three is that FEI knows actually
performed the snap because of Lady Death
and Lady Death has been taken the form
of baby Gamora all throughout Thanos
life Theory number four is that the
Avengers actually won't use the quantum
realm to time-travel but the Avengers
will go to neduvaali R and then Thor
will go to the seven realms and gather
an army to fight against Thanos and
theory number five is that in the second
Avengers and game trailer in the scenes
where all the destruction is happening
is actually ons and R so those are this
week's theories for Theory Thursday be
sure to vote on which one you thought
was your favorite and again if you would
like to submit your own theory for a
chance to end up an episode you can find
the email to send it to and the
instructions in the description down
below and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on all Theory Thursdays and
everything relating to Marvel and
Avengers endgame as always thank you all
so much for watching we'll fool
[Music]